je te faire unitaire du sang conneries
et à l'issue de cette interview sur
connerie il y aura une magnifique
surprise portable quand je vous une
surprise mais de ouf et dans un instant
vers et qui a été éliminée numéro quatre
sur le poteau pour le moment mon co et
comment on devient drôle quand on a vécu
une en faut une enfance pas drôle du
tout parce que c'est vrai que ce que tu
dit dans son livre nous on va là on
l'enlève tous lui ici et on s'est dit
déjà comment tu fais pour devenir drôle
tu t'es dit c'est le seul moyen de m'en
sortir
ouais sérieusement oui c'est à dire que
ce livre en fait c'est vrai qu'il dit
des bars ap les premières pages sont
très tristes
il ya plein d'anecdotes ex-rda et voilà
parce que je parle de la disparition de
mes parents successifs à de ton père
voilà ma mère d'adoua mère d'abord et
après tombé à faire après et je crois
que c'est le livre le plus optimiste que
je vous fasse j'ai voulu vraiment faire
un livre optimisé ou livres et la manque
à cette partie est très difficile est
terrible mais j'ai voulu montrer que
quand on a des rêves quand on a envie
quand on a un truc en tête moi c'était
la radio la télé de cette région très
tôt tu lis et voilà je savais pas bien
quoi mais je voulais en tout cas faire
ce métier amuser les gens il ya un
moment donné il faut se relever et je
crois moi que l'humour m'a fait voyager
assez vite c'est à dire très vite je me
suis dit ok on va essayer de prendre la
vie avec essayer de rire de choses qui
sont pas forcément drôle parce que moi
je vivais des drames à ce moment-là
successivement et et je crois que ça a
marché je crois que si je suis devenu
celui aujourd'hui qui se moque un peu de
tout qui des fois raconte des conneries
plus grosses que lui c'est passagers
pris à ces petits cette habitude de dire
voilà dans les situations vraiment
terrible qui peuvent arriver là il faut
essayer de trouver ce qui va nous sortir
la tête de l'eau qu'est et c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on a retenti alors tu parles
de ta maman tu as perdu à l'âge de 8 ans
tu dit aussi qu'elle était très dure
avec toi il fallait jamais pleuré devant
elle est-ce que tu essayé quand même de
la feria a non pas du tout j'étais au
match était j'étais un garçon très calme
j'étais un gars ont assisté aux gentils
fois je te tue souvent plutôt calme
plutôt plutôt bon élève qui voulait
qu'une chose c'était que les choses se
passent bien à la maison et je crois que
j'étais ce qu'on pouvait être le gamin
le plus normale possible mais non et si
j'étais pas vraiment un clown
né à l'école j'étais plutôt le gamin le
plus calme du monde un peu seul dans son
coin fils unique offre des profs qui
fait il adorait j'étais pas emmerdant
j'avais des bonnes notes jetées sympa et
tout ils m'adorent rays au sud c'est
comme maxime gainey doit être comme ça
non
j'étais très sage élève moyen mais très
sage il est devenu très drôle aussi
c'est ton papa est parti très tôt suis à
la suite d'une très lourde dépression
comment t'as fait pau pour gérer tout ça
parce que tu t'es retrouvé minérale
c'est ce que tu dis et je veux tu t'es
retrouvé seul et guy voilà vraiment je
suis je suis seul j'ai plus personne
vers qui me tourner ouais j'ai eu ben
oui ça a été quand on est fils unique
j'ai reçu plein de témoignages avec ce
livre depuis qu'il est sorti depuis
jeudi dernier de maman j'ai vu encore
des messages de maman tout à l'heure qui
m'ont dit le père de notre petit garçon
est parti à quelques temps merci pour le
livre de gamme qui se retrouver orphelin
voilà qui me disent wow merci pour le
livre parce que ça veut dire que il ya
la suite derrière et c'est vrai qu'on
peut avoir l'impression dans la vie des
fois quand un drame comme ça arrive tout
s'écroule oui tout s'écroule mais tout
se reconstruit derrière moi je
commençais la radio depuis que j'avais
14 ans j'ai un âge un peu anormal pour
faire de la radio
c'est ça et quand en plus j'ai géré le
le décès de mon père etc
je devais continuer mon école de
commerce sans savoir vraiment comment
j'allais là a payé et continuent d'être
drôle à l'antenne le samedi puisque je
faisais de la radio le samedi donc très
très vite en plus je me suis raccroché à
ce métier et je pense à ma fait aussi
beaucoup de bien de me dire allez qu'est
ce que je vais pouvoir retrouver drôle
dans l'actu raconter aux gens cette
semaine vous avez 20 ans alors que je
ceci pour sortir des gens parce que tu
te disais il ya plein de gens aussi qui
doivent avant de vivre des moments
difficiles comme moi j'ai envie de les
faire marie j'ai envie voilà deux oui
j'ai essayé moi pour moi allumée jeudi à
mende et dans le livre mais je crois que
l'humour a sauvé ma vie mais c'est vrai
c'est à dire l'humour le décalage de se
dire on va prendre les choses drive
graves peuvent arriver mais il ya faut
toujours trouver cette dérision quelque
part alors tu dis à l'école normale
mandat plein de copains et toi quand il
y avait un match de foot personne
n'oublie que toi dans l'équipe le looser
tient le vilain petit canard et la tue
le tue ça t'a marqué ça ça te plaît ou
pas mais parce que j'étais un gamin
j'étais un gamin seul qu'elle ait pas
une confiance alors mais je n'avais pas
une grande confiance en moi j'étais loin
d'être beau j'étais un peu gros j'étais
donc je passe je veux pas dire ce mot à
la mode que l'on entend qui harcèlement
parce que parce que ça existe beaucoup
mais j'ai pas su bien c'est manger du
jeu du me renforcer un petit peu parce
que quand on est un peu pas le logo ce
ballet filles viennent pas j'étais pas
le chef de branches étaient plutôt
plutôt très timide dans mon coin voilà
mais j'ai décidé en grandissant et la
radio m'a donné une grande confiance en
moi parce qu'avec le micro je me cachais
derrière j'avais 13 ans et louis 14 ans
on pensait que j'en avais 20 22 puis je
commencer à raconter des conneries
énorme et ça commençait à fait rire
finalement je commençais à prendre un
peu d'assurance ben en tout cas
aujourd'hui voilà je te le dis et je le
dis très souvent dans cette émission
tu es devenu un des plus grands
animateurs voilà français je te le dis
et même pour moi tu fais partie du
vraiment je te le dis deux des meilleurs
parce que en impro j'en ai vu des
animateurs est vraiment été
impressionnant et de mecs comme toi je
vous le dis en animations il y en a un
poulet disant voilà et c'est vrai que
l'art est exceptionnel fait partie des
rares animateurs au gond d'hier soir n'a
pas regardé l'émission tu as regardé que
cauet cbc la marque en lui même sur
quatre connaît